so again your alibi is a mysterious
stranger handed you the gun made you put
your prints on it robbed the store and
then hid the gun in your underpants
well yeah if you say it like that it
don't sound believable oh hey captain
did you get my report on the Finley
murder oh yeah looks it over that's work
good thanks dad
why is everyone staring at me you just
called captain holt dad he said thanks
dad what no I didn't I said thanks man
do you see me as a father figure Peralta
no if anything I see you as a father
figure cuz you're always bothering me
Hey
show your father some respect I didn't
call him dad no no no no Jacob I take it
as a compliment it's not a big deal I
called Vivian mom once and she's my
fiancee guys jump on that Boyle has
psychosexual issues old news but you
calling hope daddy hey daddy is not on
the table here but you did call him dad
dude you shut up you've done nothing but
lie since you got here all right all
right I was lying about the holdup but
the dad thing that happy he admitted
that his alibi was a lie
it was a trap all part of my crazy
devious plan I believed you thank you
son you want to talk about it later over
a game of catch
[Music]
okay detectives let's get started
Santiago where are we with the Jay
Street drug busts our 12 keys of coke
unaccounted for but we just got a
warrant to search the dealers apartment
good take Boyle and Diaz dream team
Peralta brief us on the vandalism case
well there's no easy way to put this
Sarge but someone has been painting
wieners on squad cars and apparently
they won't stop until there's a penis
drawn on every cop car in Brooklyn
that's what he's been drawing but what
are those two little round things at the
bottom it's a button
what I assume you have a plan to catch
this gentleman did you just say
gentlemen because if so kudos and yes I
have a plan I'm gonna plant a decoy
squad car as bait
meanwhile I'll be waiting in an
undercover vehicle here
he's already tagged three you see
vehicles you can clearly spot him you
should take my minivan a minivan you all
got a problem with my minivan
my wife doesn't like it either she
wanted an SUV but those things roll man
they roll it's a good idea sergeant
we'll take the van we you're coming with
me sir with all due respect I don't need
backup it's not backup it's babysitting
well the curse is over the slump is done
Jake is back permission to take a selfie
of the two of us sir permission denied
too late
that was a good one so the rabbit's foot
worked huh yeah maybe all I know is my
mind was so numb for doing all that
boring data entry that my brain kind of
rebooted and I had an inspiration about
one of my old cases and I now see that
that was your plan all along and that
you're capable of smiling all talented
detectives have their ups and downs
Peralta so you think I'm talented you
said it no take-backs
you know what Boyle doesn't slump
because his whole life is a slump
because he doesn't like that adversity
get him down
he keeps grinding if I'd given you those
new cases the second you hit a snag he
would have spiraled again you need to
stay out of your own head okay but sir I
don't get it if that was your plan why
bother with Smitty and the rabbit's foot
well there's a very good reason for that
I
I believe the term is messing with you
oh I see what's going on here we're
becoming homies office Christmas card
candidate right here being holder homeys
boy where's my paperwork on that DOA
still waiting on the autopsy report
supposed to come in first thing this
morning but so far nothing
this is unacceptable I'll call the gummy
and find out what happened that's not
necessary sir for the record I think
it's natural causes anyway but I'm also
the secondary on this case it's my
responsibility so I will head on down
there pick up the report good but don't
ever pump up about me again right I
don't know buh-buh-buh-buh just go yep I
am going to regret teaching him that one
thank you money was still in the bookies
safe all the numbers match let's head
back to Santiago's party oh no thanks I
think I'm gonna head home and watch the
football game which was ruined for me
what's the problem with celebrating
Thanksgiving it's a sucky holiday it's
always sucked my mom worked my dad was
gone and I sat at home watching football
okay I came from a very formal family my
parents were not especially affectionate
really your honour wasn't a big snuggler
but the beauty of being an adult is that
you can make a new family with new
traditions well that's nice captain but
I don't have a new family yet so I guess
I'm stuck with my awesome old traditions
okay okay let's quad you can make it
thank you before you go can I borrow
some money and get some pretty serious
vibes from Wendy over there and I'd like
to take her someplace special
[Music]
all right my safe house my rules
this is a no tie zone a hungry safe
house is an unsafe safe house a fun safe
house is a safe safe house my sir
doctor said you've never played this
it's very intuitive let's have another
sandwich a safe house watching safe
house is a safe safe house house I've
already seen the film I enjoyed it
Wow I would not have guessed that you
see those are the kind of things that
you learn when you're handcuffed
together and that is the true meaning of
Christmas
so the burner phone that Doug Judy used
to contact the Pontiac Bandit is at his
mom's house he's agreed to help us catch
the Bandit if we drop all charges
against him
how many cars would you say this Pontiac
bandit is stolen two hundred and thirty
that I know of but the real number could
be in the millions you're not very good
at math hmm what are the charges against
you 12 counts of identity theft but I've
been chasing him for a month
Oh a month I've been trying to catch the
Pontiac bandit for eight years you know
any months that is a t14 six years
months do you need a math tutor because
the Department will provide one for you
I can't tell if you're being serious
so captain I've been thinking about this
whole missing backpack thing and what if
we find Flaco and take him down
oh are you trying to solve cj's case
behind his back to embarrass him no not
at all in fact I think CJ should come
along I just realized how important my
duty as a police officer is to me you
know the sacred oath I took your speech
really inspired me I know it's one of my
better ones
I felt really good as I was saying it
yeah so what's the plan huh well dad we
don't know where Flaco is but I have a
CI who says he's got an agreement with
Marco Severino so you think we should
pose as drug dealers looking for a new
heroin supplier and get Severino to hook
us up with Marco and you think CJ can
handle this mission I know he's
inexperienced but he's a creative guy I
think he'd be great undercover well game
with Chuck Jose let's roll up on these
muchachos great start and I love your
double use of muchachos hey it's CJ by
the way
super glue your pace your pup's ladies
because Jenkins in the house what
nevermind oh no Chuck I'm also worried
about you
come here Tim in a hug time I'd rather
not okay Boyle release him fine only
because you're ordering me to there's
nine minutes left on that hug wait it's
a head nice job and Quebec I'll bet the
local cops weren't happy you show them
up yeah well maybe not at first but by
the end they kept calling me a real
bottle which I can only assume means
hero
it means bastard but that's only because
they were jealous you did good work here
is this an allowance are you giving me
an allowance no I'm paying the bartender
for more drinks all right Robbie
nine minutes start now good evening sir
no it's not I haven't slept because I've
been going over that stupid problem now
I finally understand Kevin's side cool
so it's all better and I never have to
hear about math again quite the opposite
I know better than ever how incorrect he
is probability doesn't kick in there
ought to teach you college-level
statistics I don't know do I have to
teach you high school statistics you
have to teach you
eighth grade statisti do I have to teach
you seventh grade statistic do I have to
teach you now if you'll excuse me
detectives I need to leave them a
sniper's mail about kindergarten
statistics okay we have got to explain
this thing to captain Holt to save their
relationship and you laughed at me when
I went to that weekend long math
conference because you called it funky
cats and they're feisty Steph's that was
the name it was so cool it was not
anyway it's not about the math they
haven't seen each other because of the
night shift I just need a bone what
gross Rosa those are our dads I mean
that's not what I think captain dad is
just my boss
Wow never mind I'm teaching father the
math whatever Rosa
you